um hello everyone thank you so much for
coming my name is Eli and I am going to
talk to you today about how to
authenticate your users over the web
in today's talk we will cover what
authentication actually is and why we
need it
common ways to authenticate users and
their pros and cons and finally we'll
talk about what makes an authentication
system good and whether or not that's
the same thing as it being secure
spoiler alert not exactly
so first we have to ask what is
authentication this thing that we hear
so much about it's so important what
actually is it and what why do we need
it well
let's say I have built a service that
lives on the web without loss of
generality a web app of some kind
ideally I have at least one user
and this user will probably have some
stuff things like sensitive data or
actions that only they should be able to
perform like posting under a given
handle
as the person providing this web app to
them I want to be able to control these
things I'd like to be able to store
their data and I'd like to be able to
control whether or not they are able to
perform certain actions
now ideally I have more than one user
and this presents a problem I need to
make sure that this person has access to
their stuff and only their stuff
in other words as a web service provider
I want to verify that a given user
corresponds to a given identity that
something I Define
so that I can control their access to
data and actions appropriately
so
how do we do it
it turns out identity is really hard to
Define philosophically let alone
programmatically
so instead we use abstractions things
you know things you have things you are
but these are abstractions and they can
leak they can only ever be approximate
we can have a look at some options for
these kind of abstractions we've got
things like a username and password
based system something you know
you can have uh access to an existing
identity as a proxy for identity
you can have things that you are
biometrics and you can have things that
you have for example access to a
particular Hardware with unique
properties and you can also have things
like access to one-time passwords
this can all get a little bit
overwhelming so let's start by talking
about one that hopefully will be
familiar to everybody in this room
username and password
um so what we do here is we have a web
app and this web app has some server
code that runs somewhere securely you
can trust all the code that runs here
you have a client that runs on trusted
code and this is presented to the end
user and then you have your end user
if the user wants to authenticate they
put in their data their username and
password the client then sends that to
the server and the server is able to
verify that these pieces of data
correspond to the identity the user is
trying to claim
the server thing they then go back to
the client say Yep this person is who
they say they are and then the user is
authenticated
this is so far so familiar right
in this world we are assuming that
knowledge of this password is equivalent
to Identity that's the abstraction that
is being used in this scenario
that means that if you know that
password you can assume that identity so
it's really important to keep track of
who knows that password
obviously the user has to and the client
is easy we don't have to store data we
can simply pass it through to the server
but the server is interesting actually
because it doesn't have to know the
password necessarily but it does have to
be able to verify that the password is
correct the server has the following
responsibilities it must be able to
verify the password in order for
authentication to work but it has to
protect the password from being
disclosed
in an naive world we might store records
like this username and password
fantastic the server gets the password
checks it against the records that it
has all is well and good
but then when our server is breached all
of these identities are immediately
compromised
fortunately there is an answer to this
and it has hash functions hash functions
are one-way functions that can take an
input and produce a unique output and
what we have here is we have a sort of
pseudo code thing where I'm putting in a
password along with a bit of extra
random data called salt
I'm plugging that into the hash function
and it gets some output that's a garbled
string of characters and that is what we
store on the server along with the salt
so your records end up looking like this
this means that if your data is breached
if your if your server is breached
somebody who has this salted hash can no
longer immediately just plug that back
in and gain access to your identity
um and you can see that it's stored the
salt per user so when the the server
receives the password it can go ah I
need to add that salt 7af in this
example plugs that into my hash function
and check that it matches the second
half of what I've got stored there
however
this is still a little bit vulnerable
because most people choose passwords
that are easily memorable made up of
English words for example and given
enough time and a sufficiently big
computer somebody with access to your
salted hash can derive your password
there's a way around this too it
involves remembering passwords that look
like this to begin with
so
you have now made password-based
authentication pretty secure all you
need to do is remember as many passwords
like this don't reuse your passwords
for every service that you have
and this is why password-based
authentication isn't the bl1 handle
because users can forget their passwords
um you know you have to be able to have
some method of account recovery users
can be tricked into giving away their
password and a type of attack called
phishing I want to go and log into my
favorite online shop but I typo the URL
and I end up on one that looks exactly
the same and I put in my password and
now somebody else has my password
and if I've reused that password
elsewhere all of those identities are
also now compromised
so
how can we do better than this
well this is where the idea of
multi-factor authentication comes in
a multi-factor authentication is when
you require more than one thing in order
to verify that a user is who they say
they are in other words we mitigate the
risk of one abstraction failing by
requiring multiple abstractions to
succeed
so even if one leaks hopefully two or
more won't all at the same time
authentication factors can be things
that you know like a password they can
be things that you have like access to
specialized Hardware
and they can be things that you are like
Biometrics this one is particularly
interesting because the abstraction here
is well my fingerprint genuinely is as
good a proxy for identity as we have
but the abstraction is actually in
turning that fingerprint into something
a computer can understand I have to
trust my fingerprint scanner that's
where things can get a little bit dicey
with biometrics
and if your biometric is compromised
it's a lot easier to get a new password
than it is to get a new thumb
so when we require multiple
authentication factors we could require
two things that you know
this isn't great though because if
somebody's managed to compromise one
secret that I know they may well be able
to use the exact same method to
compromise a second thing that I know so
generally when we do multi-factor
authentication it's best to mix them up
something you know and something you
have or something you are and this is
superior
so
what are some options for multi-factor
Authentication
we are going to take a tour of other
authentication factors and I'm going to
start with Hardware authentication
tokens and I'm just going to grab
my ubikey
so Hardware authentication tokens are
things like a UB key and they're also
sometimes built into things like a
platform authenticators that are built
into your phone or your laptop
um and to understand what they actually
do we have to know a little bit about
public key cryptography so basic primer
public key cryptography works by having
key pairs a private key that you keep to
yourself and you never share and a
public key that you do share and that's
sort of your identity
and then if I want to send some
information to somebody that has my
public key I can use my private key to
encrypt it and the person who has my
public key can use that key to decrypt
and verify the message that I sent them
and then they know that it was me that
sent it
so what Hardware tokens do is they
physically embody that private key baked
in at the hardware level
the way that you use them to
authenticate looks like this you've got
the same setup client server and user or
you know
and I go to my web service and I say I'd
like to log in and the client goes to
the server and says this person wants to
log in they have a hardware token
associated with them and the server says
okay I'm going to make a request for
their hardware token
the user then presents their hardware
token and that request from the server
gets passed to it the hardware token
then does all the cryptographic
processing necessary to confirm its
identity and sends that back to the
client who passes it through to the
server which uses its knowledge of your
public key to verify that message and
then you can be authenticated
there were several quite interesting
things about this flow one of them is
that the device knows about the web
service that's making the authentication
request
it's easy for me to typo a website and
end up on something that looks very
similar I won't notice the difference
but my hardware token will and it won't
work if phishing attacks are rendered
much much less dangerous when you're
using a hardware token
another thing is that the private key
never leaves the device all the
cryptography happens on the device
itself when you're dealing with platform
authenticators ones that are built in to
larger devices there's actually a layer
a hardware layer sort of insulation
and what this means is that no matter if
my computer is riddled with malware
nobody can extract that private key and
get hold of that secret
now it would be possible potentially to
Brute Force the private key out of a out
of a hardware token if your computer was
in fact riddled with malware and to
protect against this many Hardware
tokens I think almost all require user
presence in order to do that
cryptographic processing so for Hardware
tokens that are like a ubikey that might
be pressing a button for once built into
a platform authenticator they might
require a biometric check and this is
where sort of this is where you'll see
Biometrics used in authentication mostly
it's in order to activate a hardware
token
so this is great right these completely
solved security
what are the issues well
they're expensive
my ubq was 60 quid
um not prohibitive for somebody on a tax
salary but if you are going to require
this of all the users of your web
service you have to be very sure that
they'll be willing to do that
they can also be lost these are physical
objects I have major ADHD I am
absolutely going to lose this at some
point and when I do I'm going to need to
be able to reset it everywhere that I
have used it to verify my identity
another option is one-time passwords
if you've ever received a text that
looks like this you'll be familiar
these are well they're passwords that
work for Bond go and you'll usually
receive them by text or in an
authenticator app on your smartphone
the way that this works is probably
familiar to many people you go to your
web app and you say I'd like to log in
the client says cool the server is going
to go and generate you a code that code
gets sent to your device you read that
code and enter it the client is able to
verify it either by making another
server call or in the browser directly
and you are authenticated
this is great it means that you don't
have to necessarily have an expensive
hardware token in order to do something
you have method of Authentication
um it does rely on a couple of things so
if you're doing text-based
authentication you have to be pretty
sure that nobody can clone your sim and
just also get your texts uh this is a
particular vulnerability that I think uh
Reddit came a Cropper of this I think a
few years ago 2018 where they were using
text-based multi-factor authentication
and somebody did this and gained access
to administrator accounts
you can also lose your phone
you can also be in a place without phone
signal so it's not necessarily going to
be accessible all of the time I get
absolutely garbage phone signal in my
new house and um I I will always ask for
the two-factor authentication code via
email instead
speaking of email
there's another option which is
magiclink login slack uses this hands up
who uses Slack
yeah you've almost certainly use this
and it looks like this
um the way that this works is you go to
your web app and you say I'd like to log
in here's who I am
and the client goes to the server and
says hey please send an email to this
person including a link to an
authenticated session so including some
kind of token that lives within the
email
sent the user clicks on that link from
their email and is taken to an
authenticated session in the browser now
we have to assume that email
communication is secure for this
safe assumption if somebody's cracked
your Gmail you probably have bigger
things to worry about than whether or
not your Indie yarn shop is also at risk
um
and it's pretty good because most people
have email accounts and unlike phone
signal you can assume that if somebody's
trying to log into your online service
they have an internet connection to
check their email
however
you can lose access to email accounts at
work we get a lot of people who are like
oh I signed up with a student account
and I've lost access can you transfer
ownership or cancel it or any number of
things
so you need to be able to handle that
situation where somebody has lost access
to the thing that we're using as a proxy
for identity
so
think about how many online accounts you
have Facebook Google Twitter my online
Indie yarn shop Tumblr whatever
think about setting up two-factor
authentication for all of these
and then think about losing your yubikey
and having to go back and reset it
everywhere that you've used it
alternately think about how many online
accounts you use for work slack GitHub
jira there's you know lots and lots of
them AWS whatever and think about being
the sysadmin of a company with all those
employees in it you have to administrate
all of those accounts for all of those
employees and all of their
authentication factors
and while MFA makes things more secure
sometimes that overhead will put people
off
how can we do better
this is where the idea of single sign-on
comes in
single sign-on is the idea that you have
one centrally managed identity and you
can use that in multiple places to
authenticate
so in this world of single sign-on we
have two entities to consider a service
provider this is my Indie yarn shop
and an identity provider this is
something like Google or OCTA and what
happens is that when I log in with my
service provider actually I'm using the
identity provided by the identity
provider
this has uh some a lot of benefits
for example I only had to set up a
multi-factor in one place and Protect
One account with it if I lose my UB key
that's one place I have to reset it if I
want to update aspects of my identity
new car details address name change that
can happen in one place and I can see
all of those benefits and changes
reflected across all of the services
that I've used this identity with
it also so the way that it works
abstractly is that I as a user go to my
service provider and I said I'd like to
log in I'm then redirected to the
identity provider and I authenticate
there with whatever means I've chosen
you can have strong authentication here
lots of
multi-factor everything that you want
your Biometrics your one-time passwords
the whole works
you're then logged in there
and the identity provider sends you back
to your service provider with some kind
of token of proof that the service
provider can use somehow to verify that
you are who you say you are and log you
in there this is a very high level look
we'll look at Frameworks in a moment
now there are quite a few benefits to
this not just as a user but as a
developer it means well delegating
authentication to a third party means a
few things
you as a web service don't need to store
user credentials
I don't need to worry about my Indie
yarn shop getting compromised because it
never had to store store authentication
details it delegated it all to Google
it means that you don't have to worry
quite so much about what data you store
and how you store it
users don't need to remember lots of
passwords they need to remember their
authentication details for one service
you can have one big long random string
of characters that you remember and
that's all you need
there are some downsides if your
identity provider is compromised
everywhere that you've used that
identity will also be compromised it
sort of seems a bit counter-intuitive
that putting all your eggs in one basket
in this way can be more secure but
consider Google security budget is a lot
bigger than mine
we do see your identity providers
getting compromised OCTA had a breach
earlier this year but it's far less
likely than a small web service provider
with a small Dev team who just aren't
able to take into account all the
security considerations that a big
identity provider is able to
so how can we implement this this lovely
abstract idea
there are two mainstream methods that
I'm going to talk about one is saml
which is security assertion markup
language and the other is open ID
connect often abbreviated to oidc
so let's talk about saml
saml uses XML data as its language for
expressing authentication requests and
assertions of identity and the way that
it works is you have a saml service
provider and a saml identity provider I
as a user go to my saml service provider
samlers typically used these days in
sort of Enterprise situations so let's
say that this is my payroll system I
want to get my latest pay slip
so
I would say I want to get my payslip I
need to log into the payroll system
I am then redirected in my browser to
the identity provider
and that comes along with a saml
authentication request this is a blob of
XML data containing things like what
method I need to use to authenticate who
I'm claiming to be and this should all
be cryptographically signed by a private
key
the saml identity provider has knowledge
of the public key is able to decrypt
that XML data parse it understand who
I'm trying to be and what it needs to do
to verify that and I'm able to
authenticate
I'm then redirected back in my browser
back to the service provider along with
an authentication assertion this is
another blob of XML data that contains
things like yes this person
authenticated at this time using this
method
this is also cryptographically signed
the sample service provider is able to
decrypt and pass this data use it to
verify that I am who I say I am and
authenticate me
there are a few interesting things about
this flow one of them is that everything
is happening in the browser with
redirects and XML data attached these
two entities the service provider and
the identity provider never talk to each
other directly that means that the your
identity provider can actually be closed
from the public web it could be running
on a closed company Network for example
but you can be using the identity that
it provides to authenticate with things
that are on the public web that's pretty
cool
um there are some downsides though and
one of the big ones is that signing XML
data is hard
cryptographic signing happens over byte
strings
XML is an incredibly permissive language
it allows you to express the same thing
in multiple different ways that makes
signing it really hard
for an example of this let's look at
these two pieces of XML
you see the problem right
these two things semantic they have the
same semantic meaning they mean the
issuer in this piece of saml data is
whatever is in between these two tags
but if I were to sign these
cryptographically I would come out with
two separate values
and that means that
um it could be passed differently by
people on the other end
what we need to do is we need to find
some way of looking at these two pieces
of saml and extracting the semantic
meaning of them this process is called
canonicalization
and canonicalization often includes the
idea that you have extracted the
semantic meaning and then recomposed it
into a canonical form like the way to
say this thing in saml is this
particular blob of XML
now there's an issue with this
um the issue with this is that in the
saml spec there is not any one
particular preferred canonicalization
algorithm
there is for a given language there may
be more than one implementation of a
given algorithm
um and your service provider and your
identity provider are gonna have to
agree
if there's a mismatch in how they are
understanding the XML data that's being
passed between them that's that's uh an
Avenue for an attacker to you know to
exploit there have been sample exploits
that allow people to just log in as
admin with absolutely no sort of you
know authentication required basically
there's a kind of vulnerability baked
into saml
um by dint of the fact that it uses XML
this incredibly flexible and permissive
language provides an enormous attack
surface
and this was the first type of SSO that
we had it was used sort of in
corporations who basically ran into the
problem of my employees have all these
accounts how can I administrate them in
centrally manage identity
and for a long time it was good enough
um you know vulnerabilities appeared and
were patched and you know I'm not sure
that there is a completely invulnerable
saml implementation out there but you
know it got the job done however if that
had been all that we had SSO might not
have taken off as much as it has among
the general population
this is where openid connect comes in
and open ID connect is what you you've
probably used it if you've ever seen a
screen that looks like this
and openid connect is built on top of
oauth which is an authorization
framework and it inherits some qualities
from that framework I'm not going to
talk about authorization in this talk
because it's an entire conference talk
in its own right but one of the things
that you get from it is you have an
identity server with multiple endpoints
and this turns out to be very useful for
secure Authentication
so the main differences between oidc and
saml are as follows
oidc uses Json web tokens rather than
XML to encrypt and transmit data and
claims about who a person is and
requests for that Authentication
this is better because well Json web
tokens have sort of various
vulnerabilities they are standardized in
a way that XML data cannot be there is a
standard way of writing a given Json web
token and there are golden paths for
like there are preferred
canonicalization or preferred ways of
cryptographically signing them
um it is possible to have set your
cryptographic it is possible to set your
encryption algorithm to be none in a
Json web token don't recommend it
um but there are standards that are
widely adopted for signing Json web
tokens and being able to encrypt them
securely reliably and have agreement
between all parties as to what the data
actually means in a way that isn't true
for XML
another thing is that the tokens that
are passed back to the service provider
are possible by the service provider
they can extract data from them but the
service provider isn't responsible for
verifying them it can go back to the
identity provider directly communicating
and say hey this token you've given me
is this legit you know have I I've or
rather I've been given this token can
you tell me that this is legitimate and
this is a very strong defense against
things like malicious tokens
um that are sort of injected somehow the
service provider has recourse to go back
to the identity provider and double
check
so the way that this login flow works is
very similar but there are obviously the
differences that you just talked about
you'll notice that the oidc
authentication server is serving as the
identity provider
so I've come to my web service I want to
log in I am redirected in my browser to
an authorization endpoint on the
identity server this is where I
essentially authorize the identity
server to let me log in with the service
provider so I do that using my
multi-factor Authentication
and then I am redirected back to in my
browser to the service provider along
with an authorization code
and as a user my point in the flow is
now done
what the service provider now does is it
takes that authorization code and goes
back to the server to a different
endpoint and says I've been given this
authorization code this user has
authorized me to log in on their behalf
please can you give me a token that I
can use to understand who this user is
and the authentication server does so it
sends back an ID token and this ID token
it's sort of it's a bit of a misnomer to
call it a token that is what it's
referred to in all of the documentation
in the spec really what it is is a
record of authentication that token says
this person authenticated with me at
this time using this method
and that may be enough for the service
provider to be confident logging you in
this uh this is sort of this can be the
end of the login flow
but there's an optional step where the
service provider can take that ID token
and go to the introspection endpoint on
the authentication server and say hey I
have this token can you verify that this
is real for me and maybe I can have some
more information about this person
something like an email address
that will depend on how you as the user
have set up your identity with that
authentication server as to what extra
information is available to the service
provider at this point
but basically the service provider has a
method by which it can look at a token
that it's been given and have an extra
step of trust and verification
and the oidc server gets that token and
can then tell you yes and can tell the
service provider yes this person did
authenticate at this time this is
legitimate and it could know this
because of all of these tokens being
cryptographically signed and at this
point the service provider can be very
confident in authenticating the user
um so this is the kind of SSO that's
taken over the world it's what you end
up like you know you can there's
multiple big identity providers like
Google opta you can use GitHub you can
log in with Twitter and this is how all
of those work
um one of the really big benefits of SSO
in general but oidc in particular is
that I had a user at any point can go to
the authentication server to my identity
provider and say hey I don't want you to
let
this other this web service log in with
this this identity anymore I want to
turn off permissions for whatever web
service and that means you can actually
revoke access
um to your to your identity to any
service provider any point um this is
very useful if for example I don't know
yeah you want to stop using it
um it's an extra layer of user control
over how your identity is used
so
we have now looked at a few different
methods of authentication we've gone
through username and password and we
have gone through lots of different
multiple authentication Factor options
like Hardware tokens one-time passwords
magic Link login and the various kinds
of SSO
we are now ready to talk about what
makes an authentication system good
so there's an obvious gimme right off
the bat so
our authentication system isn't secure
then there's no point having it in the
first place right you may as well just
you know let everybody access
everybody's details
to that end I would invite us to take
another look at our username and
password example
now we discussed how this can actually
be made technically secure it involves
you remembering lots of passwords like
this
in fact it involves you remembering lots
of passwords like this
and password managers aside use a
password manager protect it with 2fa it
can kind of be considered a type of SSO
but that is again a conference talk in
and of itself probably
um
this requirement on the user in order to
make this system secure leads to
insecure behaviors like password reuse
writing down passwords simply adding a
number that increments to the end of
your password every place that you use
it all of the things all of the
behaviors that people adopt when they're
asked to rotate their password or to you
know get a new password every three
months
um and this makes it it makes it
insecure even though technically it's
secure the burden on the user makes it
insecure if something is hard to use
securely
it's insecure
um and I would caution against the idea
that like you know I make a developer
tool all my all my users are developers
they're smart they won't they won't
engage in these behaviors right
my boss smartest person I know pasted
his master password into slack a few
months ago
you can never rely on your users being
perfect do not rely on this you it's
simply not true it's unfair to ask and
you'll end up building systems that are
insecure as a result
so if something is hard to use securely
that makes it insecure and compromises
our first tenet of security so I would
argue that there is a second tenant here
and that is ease of use for your end
users
let's take another look at saml
if implemented correctly and securely
which is theoretically possible
this is very user friendly it's SSO it
comes with all of the benefits that we
know and love not having to remember
multiple passwords centralized identity
management
you know and it is secure if you do it
correctly
but I mean I could go on and on about
the reasons why it is hard to do
correctly but this place is an enormous
burden on the developers to stay up to
date in breaches in XML cryptography
um to stay up to date with anything
that's come up as issues in the
libraries that you're using to make sure
that you you know cover all of your
bases and with the incredible attack
surface that this method has
that's really really hard
I don't know that anybody has ever
written a completely secure saml
implementation
and this means that if something is hard
to implement securely it insecure
um usability matters not just for the
users but for us as Developers if we're
taking on an enormous maintenance burden
of a system that's going you know that's
that's sort of a different kind of user
friction it's a friction that happens
within the system and can cause it to
break down over time if you don't
maintain your systems if those systems
are hard to maintain and maintained
securely then you're going to end up
with something that's insecure
so I would argue that uh there is a
third pillar of what makes an
authentication system good
and that is ease of implementation
now these three things might seem to be
in Conflict at various points and that's
probably true we live in a world of
trade-offs when we come to developing
things but I think that if you consider
all of these at each stage like design
stage of how you're going to
authenticate your users you'll end up
with a much better product at the end
so for example one-time password sent by
text might have some security issues
um you know the Sim cloning thing we
talked about earlier
that doesn't make them worse than
nothing at all and if that is the thing
that's going to be easiest to use for
your users and easiest to implement for
your developers it might be the right
choice
if you can find something that checks
all three of these boxes completely then
congratulations you found the Holy Grail
um but I would argue that neglecting any
one of these is going to lead to
building something that is not secure
and therefore not worth having
so I am wrapping up way ahead of time
but we have talked about what
authentication is and why you need it
we've talked about how we do it and the
various pros and cons of various methods
why all of them are hard actually
and how to do it well and the fact that
usability matters for us for our users
and for the system as a whole
um yeah that wraps me up thank you so
much for coming I have a lot of time for
questions
[Applause]
if anyone wants to ask me for more
ranting about saml I have that in the
bag
I'm just going to bring the microphone I
can't see if people are holding up their
hands by the way I'm sorry
so what's your view on we're both in and
how does it fit into the things cool so
um webble then is a web standard that
basically dictates how the use of
Hardware tokens should be expressed
within a web framework
um so the standards that Define how
Hardware tokens work are called fido2
and there are two things that contribute
to this there's how the hardware should
communicate with the system it's plugged
into like what goes on when I plug this
UV key in and what's the data
transmission there that's called ctap I
forget what it stands for
and then how your com how that data
that's then on your computer your OS
whatever how that should interact with
the web that's web authen so web or then
um defined if my web service is going to
ask for a hardware token how does it do
that what's the language what can it ask
for what can it assume
um and so those two standards together
basically mean that you can trust that
your hardware token and your web service
are going to play nicely together that's
what 502 is and that's why you'll see
Keys being described as 502 compliant so
that is part of the hardware token stuff
um it's really really cool because it
basically means that your web service
can
basically have its behavior and that
behavior can be guaranteed to work with
any kind of hardware token because there
are it's not just ubiky there are
multiple manufacturers
um and it basically sort of it's yeah
it's a really well-defined API for
anybody who's building either a web
service or designing a hardware token
needs to meet
um does that answer the question
take this question at the back here
when I go to some Publisher's website
and they want me to sign in with say
Google or Facebook and I click the
button I then get sent off to to Google
who knows a lot about me and then they
take a sort of a bunch of stuff which I
can't necessarily see much about because
it's encrypted and send it back to this
publisher who hopefully doesn't know a
whole heap about me what is there
anything in play that would help the the
user to get some visibility into what
that data looks like or how much is
being shared about them yeah so this is
where we get into the sort of
distinction between authentication and
authorization
so basically when you use oidc there's a
sort of limited amount of data that gets
sent about you to the web service
and ideally when you go to your web
service to your identity provider you
should be able to control that I haven't
actually been in the Google settings and
say hey when I log in with so and so do
they have access to my emails do they
have access to this that the other
um that's one of the things sometimes
you'll see Services say oh this service
wants to access your your photos in your
Google Drive in your Google cloud or
whatever
um and whether or not web services are
authorized to use those pieces of data
about you is more of an oauth thing than
an oidc thing
um and it's really complicated is the
answer but the in an ideal world you
would be able to go to your identity
provider and actually see that data as a
user it may not be in Google's best
interests to allow you to do that but
you know in a in a sort of um in an
ideal world where they don't profit off
of our data quite as much as they do
that might be more possible I'm not
saying it's not possible I don't know
um
yeah
it's it's sort of um it's a bit of a
gray area basically and it's because of
the fact that oidc is built on top of
this authorization framework which is a
much more complex and kind of finely
grained thing than just Authentication
sorry that that's very rambling I don't
know if it answers your question exactly
but um yeah
and thanks very much for the
presentation I heard that or I thought
I'd read a couple months back that both
apple and and Google through their
Android platform were looking at trying
to sort of implement web orphan into the
phones or the the platforms going
forward so that at some point
it's it's available as an option and I'm
just I didn't quite understand how like
whether the 502 we're both in whether
that was possible or whether really it's
only possible on you know that UB key or
a similar Hardware take or whether I'm
just interested in your view as to
whether you think it's possible because
it occurs to me look
everyone's got to find just about if if
if that does happen and they roll it out
and it's a standard feature of all fines
does that get us down the pathway of
solving this problem
yes
um so I I noticed Phil looking excited I
believe his talk touches on very similar
things so go to his talk he's he's the
expert on this
um as you say Hardware tokens are now a
normal feature of many many devices
smartphones primary among them I think
my understanding of the pro The Proposal
here is that instead of like I have a
password for my Google accounts that's
that is the primary authentication
factor is this thing that I know and
then having a hardware token or a mobile
number associated is the secondary
authentication Factor my understanding
is that they want to flip it so the
ownership of a hardware token probably
within a phone on a Google OS becomes
the primary secret that identifies you
and from there you don't need a password
you just need physical access to your
phone
um I'm just having a horrible flashback
to the time that I dropped my phone in
the middle of the road and it got run
over multiple times that's that's my
fear about that um so I think obviously
this is something that anybody designing
the assistance would have thought about
um and will have had ways to think about
how to mitigate the problems you know
the the equivalent problem of forgetting
your password is losing physical access
to this thing
um I think it could be really
interesting because it would change a
lot of the ways that um sort of phishing
attacks and various various cyber
attacks have to be conceived so
the thinking
to your kind of platform account as well
as well those
I former authenticator allows you to
sync your tokens across to your account
so if you drop your phone
under your Android phone it's still able
to sync back from
your iPhone
can come back from your iCloud
again it does
and doesn't get lost
I mean on the uh on the topic of keys
getting lost I um I did a podcast
episode of net rocks back in uh recorded
at NC London this past year and one of
the things I spoke about with Rich
Campbell at that point was he has
multiple
um UB keys and he's got this great
system for if he loses one knowing which
one it is and being able to back it up
and having multiple Hardware tokens are
registered to a single account and
that's a really clever way I think of
mitigating that particular failure mode
to which I am extremely prone
um yeah is that does that answer your
question I mean I think the real answer
is going to be go to first talk
I'll just bring the microphone up
on the left first
um continuing on the topic of Hardware
tokens
uh presumably the computer that you're
accessing the website from needs to have
some sort of driver installed so that
the hardware token works is that ever a
problem if you say logging in from like
a public library computer or something
that's really locked down
um I would I would assume not I think
that's the domain of what ctap is there
to to mandate that's what that sort of
standard is there to ensure that the
idea that whatever computer you are
accessing you're you're sort of using as
a pass through is able to handle that
communication
um there may well be computers that
aren't c-tap compliant I guess
um one interesting thing about it is
that obviously you can have UB keys I
think this one has NFC on it there are
various modes of Transport that are
defined within ctap so you can have
Bluetooth and NFC and then physical USB
connection
um and there are different
uh
requirements for how that data is
transferred
um
yeah I I think it's entirely possible
that our computers that are not ctap
compliant but I would imagine that the
designing of that spec was done to be as
permissive as possible to various types
of computers because essentially it's
just they're just like sea structs that
get passed back and forth
um and the the schema of all of those is
what's defined in ctab
um
yeah that's very interesting I want to
go away and look that up now
so can I ask a question to this room
give about think about authentication
providers and is that uh
on my company we got kind of badly burnt
by one of the authentication providers
when they all of a sudden up the price a
few hundred times yep and so what I'm
wondering is how many people here have
implemented their own identity service
provider like identity server versus how
many are buying the service like author
or
yeah all the other ones that are out
there so raise your hands if you're
using your own implementation oh you
think no or yeah or if you would come so
you're probably too easy how many are
buying that sellers
yeah thank you very much for that I I've
implemented one as a toy I certainly
wouldn't use it for anything I cared
about
it it is a lot of work to implement your
own I think most of the people that will
be rolling their own are going to be
sample service providers and there's
slightly less risk in that if you are
using it on a closed company Network
because you have a much stricter control
over who is able to access that because
if it's behind a VPN or something and
because saml doesn't require the two
entities to directly communicate you can
do that but you have to assemble
yeah you're talking about Samuel really
scares me because we have some of our
bigger clients are enforcing it upon our
identity service which is a Pure oidc
service yeah I mean what I haven't
really talked about in this talk is I
work for um I work for Anvil and we are
a platform for developing web apps and
as such we have a lot of built-in user
authentication options saml we have as a
business plan thing only and we we
rarely see people using it except in
Enterprise
um but yeah when it's a requirement
sometimes it's a hard requirement yeah
unfortunately yeah no that's good that's
good to know
foreign
just coming from
the log out perspective of this so when
you have single identity providers
organization uses one and then
customers log into
different applications and then they
decide to log out from one application
and for example our organization has
policy that there has to they have to
remain logged in
uh into the identity provider like and
maybe re-authenticate them once once a
month
but that to me leads into like it's it's
a compromise I guess between security
and ease of use right it often is um
that's often what it comes down to
what's the best practice
be as secure as you possibly can in as
long as your users will tolerate it
I mean if I if it takes me a a
fingerprint scan and a one-time password
and three different big long strings of
characters and a face scan and a retinal
scan to get into my bank account I'm
gonna start keeping my money in my
mattress which let's be honest with the
UK economy
[Laughter]
so you know you yes with with things
where you um require a lot of your users
you have to decide whether or not that
burden is going to be too much for them
um with the log out thing uh one of the
things with oidc is that you can go into
your account and say I want to revoke
access for Pinterest or whatever
um with saml that would be per identity
provider implementation if you're
rolling your own you're going to have to
implement being able to log out there is
a saml logout request it's
maybe one of the more cursed bits of the
saml spec
um I honestly I read that bit and I was
like I'm not even going to try and cover
this it's too far down the rabbit hole
um there are ways to do granular log out
I think oadc has a pretty good method of
doing that things like revoking access
tokens and so on and that's the point
where the Callback between the service
provider and the identity provider will
come into play because the service
provider will go look I've got this
token can you tell me who this is and
the service the identity provider will
go oh that's not valid anymore
um which is one of the strengths of
having those two entities be able to
directly communicate
um which is obviously something that
saml lacks both a blessing and a curse
um yeah I mean you've you have your
constraints of whatever business needs
you have as well as security and ease of
use needs that you have and you kind of
have to um yeah make the best choice
that you can under your constraints
which I think is probably the the
hardest problem in software engineering
apart from naming cash and validation
and off by one errors so
and it's an integral part of that joke
the two hardest things
let me bring the mic over oh yeah
yes okay just for their own like online
I'm all mixed up I forget that everyone
else isn't
Samuel token using jots potato teeth oh
well I mean I don't think it would be
Samuel anymore because it stands it's
it's security a certain markup language
which is an extension to XML it's kind
of that's the whole deal is that you're
using this saml language to uh express
your things so Samuel with jots I think
would be better than Samuel with XML
because of the um golden Paths of uh
encrypting them and sort of
standardization of the ways that things
are expressed within them
um
that would be a sort of halfway house
between the two the saml and oidc but
then you wouldn't get the being able to
call between the two entities directly
for extra verification but you would
preserve the ability to have your
identity provider offline
maybe for some people that's the right
approach it involves definitely rolling
your own I don't know any of the
off-the-shelf solution for that
I won't be offended if there aren't more
questions don't worry
something like that may be it cool
all right well thank you so much for
coming
um it's been a pleasure